hey guys welcome back to a brand new
video we're back on monster world again
for the third solo guide of today today
we're tackling tigress the last monster
and the monster on our world betta as
always I have to run through the
procedure really quickly this was taking
in this video is being posted during the
Monster Hunter ice-born beta on ps4 so
if you do see this video and it is
September when Monster Hunter ice-born
is fully released do not worry that
means that the monster did not change in
terms of his moveset or he didn't change
at all so you're still caught up to date
on what is with this monster and how you
can defeat him and if he was completely
drastically changed you wouldn't be
seeing this video because that means I'd
have to make an entirely new guide so
don't worry everything that is currently
in the beta is also in the full game if
you happen to be watching this when the
full game releases so do not worry about
that and since it is the beta I can't
show the physiology report because there
isn't one
so as always check the comments down
below if someone happens to discover it
or find a weakness during the beta or
when the full game releases I'll be
putting all that stuff and it is in the
comments down below so deftly go check
that out if you happen to be stumbling
through during the full game of Monster
Hunter ice-born but as I said today
we're gonna be tackling tigress he's a
returning monster in the past Monster
Hunter games a lot of people have called
him tigress tigrex I don't think tigrex
makes any sense to me somebody calling
him tigress to the rest of the video but
lots of people are excited to hear him
coming back as a character within
monster honour and me as a person who's
never played a monster on her game until
monster on her world I'm just as equally
excited to be facing him because he
seems like a fresh new threat to me but
to other people he's just an old monster
but with the master rank abilities and
stuff that he has being a lot more
tougher but it's still a fun fight
nonetheless some small tips for tigress
is that he's not considered an elder
dragon so you can't rank and capture him
and that should work
paralysis and poison is told as
effective as is the other two monsters
within the beta and possibly sleep as
well me using the dual plates I don't
know if the ranged weapons got any sleep
mo but for the dual Boyd's of course we
didn't get any sleep knife so I couldn't
test this and since we don't have the
report as I previously mentioned it does
seem that his head and arms bee were the
most images the head being the most
damaging part but first you fight him in
this little ice caves these little wind
holes you can see actually shoot you in
the air and pair that with a glider
mantle and you can mount him very
quickly in the very beginning of the map
but t-rex is definitely a very fast and
aggressive monster and if you've been a
veteran monster owner he's probably no
different as you fought him before in
the past games he has a lot of attacks
one being this leap which will come up
regardless of where you are if you're
too close he'll hit you but if you're
far away you can dodge just by diving or
running sideways away from the attack
both work in both options
he loves to spam this charge move as
well diving costs more stamina and it's
not actually required you can sprint
away and sometimes I was able to just
jog away from the movie not to take any
damage the one thing about t-rex that
I've noticed that he really likes to
pressure you and if you stop to heal
it's going to make this fight a lot
harder so having a build with skills
that are able to heal on hit like I said
I think the nurger ghonte set actually
does this if you have most of the pieces
so having a set like that is going to be
very usable but if you don't have the
time to do that a health booster will
come in handy as well and just place
that reward just make sure T Gurkhas
always around that with you so you can
still keep up the pressure while
fighting and not losing so much health
and then having to heal that's gonna
slow down the pace of the fight you're
gonna be taking longer to kill him and
he's gonna be doing a lot more moves
while you're trying to heal and it's
just a pain in the ass and just it's not
a good idea
he can also slash you with one of his
arms if you dodge forward you can
actually get closer allowing you to
dodge this move and get some extra hits
and he also loves to throw I see you
from a distance this will knock you over
if hit if you happen to be dead middle
of this move then dive to negate any
damage or if you're on the outskirts of
it you could simply run or jog away out
of range and he'll most likely miss you
I shown on screen his spin move is next
and it's only really happens when you're
close to him and I find this to be one
of his more favorite moves in his kit
some people have said that you can dodge
this if you go near his head as you can
duck under his tail I cannot confirm
this to be true nor false so let me know
in the comments below since I have not
been able to succeed with this type of
knowledge so just let me know if this is
actually true he also has another bite
attack where he slashes told you going
from your left here right if you dodge
your left err or run left after the
first hit you can prevent the second hit
from hitting you allowing you to get
some free hits while he recovers from
the move if that sounds a bit too
confusing don't worry you'll see an
image on the screen of that in this next
area ice actually ends up falling
throughout the area and this has only
happened one time to me but Tigers can
actually get caught if he's placed with
the Isis and he will attempt to climb
back up I'm fairly certain you cannot
you can't actually stop him and push him
over the edge because I feel like that'd
be a bit too cheesy but while he's
climbing up you can actually get some
free hits because I'm he's just trying
to climb up and not really attack you so
let's basically free hits on his
forehead but do be aware when he does
come up he will do a little bit of a
jump move so that might knock you over a
little bit maybe do that knock a down
damage not some not a lot of damage but
that small movement when the monster
does hit you
so just do be aware that might stop you
in your tracks if you're in the middle
of a combo but when T Kirk's is agitated
he can attempt to do this combo where he
does the charge and then spin move
immediately after I just fall I move
away from this move just in case during
this part it seems to happen often if
not all the time when he's agitated so
be aware when you see that in the
top-right that it says he is agitated or
if you have the skill agitator if it
does proc do be aware for that variation
of the move set and I've also seen T
groups trip when doing this charge move
I don't know what the conditions are if
it happens to just be random well health
exhaustion I have no idea but it can
happen so do be aware when he does that
rush him as quick as possible encounter
and for that extra damage because he's
gonna be acting as if he's fallen or
you've knocked him out she can get some
extra a little bit of free hits before
he tries to get up and those are really
all the moves that he has recap just
make sure to bring a health booster or
build with a skill that regains health
on hit like the nerd ghonte said I do
believe has this and then this will help
you pressure him and give you that upper
hand because like I said if you're
trying to heal while he's attacking you
it's not going to be a huge win for you
he's going to be absolutely pounding you
to the ground so having the availability
to heal while also doing damage is
perfect for him you can be dodging his
attacks and even if you do take some
damage you could always just lay on the
ground and he won't be able to attack
you and if you have a health booster
that's even better because then you'll
be healing while you're not even moving
yeah let me know in the comments below
what you guys think about tea Greeks me
play me of never playing monster hunter
before monster on our world I'm actually
really excited to fight tigress in the
main game probably returning players let
me know hottie Grix has basically
differed from the past games or if he's
the exact same this more aggressive fast
wyvern type monster yeah he's definitely
one of my favorites I still think Bo is
my favorite so far in the beta but I
gotta give second place to Teager she's
really fast and aggressive and me
playing the dual blades it was a really
nice dancing of swords there and
clashing it was really cool to see that
hey guys it's gonna be the end of the
vta hope you guys did enjoy like I said
if you guys have any other tips
definitely let me know in the comments
below like the video enjoy subscribe if
you're new I cover all the solo guides
for the monsters in Monster Hunter world
I've covered
a lot of the main elder dragons and
other stuff in the base game as well as
the care as well as the newest monsters
coming into monster hunter world
ice-born I'm gonna be covering Velka of
Elcano when he releases I've covered one
borrow BIA totus tigress and any other
monster in between that happens to
release with this DLC I will be covering
them for solo guide so definitely stay
on the channel and look out for that
during September my two most recent
videos are gonna be popping up on screen
if you guys do want to check that out
that guys so a bit of girls today I
think for watching the video and peace
out enjoy the rest of the beta
[Music]